so this uh this bottom gear shifter  actually activates the props and so  you'll hear them turn on here in a  second we're gonna push those we're  gonna keep the car in seconds so the  wheels keeps turning let off the clutch  avoid  that massive piece of metal  yeah we're  oh my gosh  [Music]  [Music]  i was looking for something fun i mean i  live out by the lake in the desert so  that is part of my retirement plan  i won't say how much the last couple  have sold at auction but it's uh a lot  more than i paid for  this just made my day  see what happens when you come down to  the lake  pretty soon i'll just be able to drive  across the lake yeah  [Music]  this is rose regatta red uh it's color  from the background was called forgotten  red uh ambi cars came in four colors you  could get white a robin egg blue a sea  foam green or regatta red  and so this one is rose regatta red  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  ah